est-ce que qui va de 1914 avec les
premiers tirs ailleurs la métropole
jusqu'en 2007 avec les discriminations
et l'intégration
nous étions et beurre en gestion des
arabes
les racailles et au final la chose qui
ne disparaîtra pas ses clés nous
resterons des musulmans à travers
l'histoire de ses cinq millions de
musulmans
c'est un autre regard sur l'histoire de
france qui nous est proposé nous
musulmans de france
suite et fin aujourd'hui à 16h45 sur
public sénat bonjour à tous retour ce
matin à la séance d'hier après midi
consacrée à une proposition de loi du
groupe communiste
un texte qui vise à garantir
l'indépendance du président de la
république vis-à-vis du pouvoir
économique
pour cela ce texte prévoit d'interdire
au président de la république de
recevoir tout avantage en espèces ou en
nature de la part d'une personne morale
et cela pendant toute la durée de son
mandat
cette mesure serait étendu à l'ensemble
du gouvernement par un article portant
sur la transparence financière de la vie
politique est en effet ce texte est très
politique
il s'insère dans un contexte troublé
celui de l'affairé woerth bettencourt
alors que l'on parle de possibles
conflits d'intérêts et alors que l'on
parle même d'un possible financement
illégal de la campagne de nicolas
sarkozy
et d'ailleurs dans ce texte le groupe
communiste ne manque pas de rappeler
certains mots du chef de l'état portant
sur la république irréprochable tout de
suite donc direction l'hémicycle alors
l'ordre du jour rappelle la discussion
de la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle visant à garantir
l'indépendance du président de la
république et des membres du
gouvernement vis-à-vis du pouvoir
économique présenté par madame nicole
borvo cohen seat
eliane assassi et josiane mathon-poinat
elle est membre de
hooper communiste républicain citoyen et
des sénateurs du parti de gauche dans la
discussion générale
oui on pour ester s'il vous plaît
mesdames les sénatrices alors un peu de
respect pour la séance publique s'il
vous plaît a pas du tout on est là pour
travailler aller dans la discussion
générale la parole et madame est à
madame la présidente nicole borvo cohen
seat
auteur de la proposition de loi
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
chers collègues j'ai donc l'honneur de
vous présenter une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle visant à mieux
garantir l'indépendance et président de
la république et des membres du
gouvernement vis-à-vis du pouvoir
économique comme le souligne le
rapporteur de la commission des lois se
cette proposition je le cite la volonté
de mettre les dirigeants politiques et
des responsables publics au dessus de
tout soupçon et de garantir aux citoyens
que l'exercice de mandats électoraux ou
de fonctions électives ne soit pas pour
eux pour ceux qui les détiennent pardon
l'occasion d'un enrichissement personnel
a été une préoccupation constante tout
au long de l'histoire de notre pays dès
1795 des obligations de déclaration du
patrimoine sont imposées aux élus par la
convention quand on est ainsi assurer la
confiance des membres des ans leur
menton et monsieur le jeu la rapporteure
pas ça l'a directement à la loi du 11
mars
80 1900 par d'or 88
il faut bien le dire relativement
récente et donc tardive dans la france
post révolutionnaire bien
alors certes la république s'est dotée
d'un cadre juridique destiné à éviter la
confusion d'intérêts au conflit
d'intérêt entre les missions publiques
et les intérêts privés ou particulier de
ceux qui les existe les exècre
l'indépendance des acteurs publics la
morale publique peut en principe faire
partie de notre consensus républicain
mais force est de constater qu'en
matière de transparence financière
d'entre législation est récente et bien
modeste
en effet les différentes situations sur
lesquelles le législateur a éprouvé la
nécessité de prévenir et ou sanctionner
d'éventuels manquements aux vertus
républicaines
concernant les élus principalement les
fonctionnaires ont donné lieu à des
règles
éligibilité d'incompatibilité entre
fonctions électives et professions
fonction ou encore au statut de la
fonction publique les obligations de
transparence concernent principalement
le financement des partis politiques
et on voit les insuffisances les
campagnes électorales et le patrimoine
des élus
hélas on peut constater aujourd'hui tous
les jours que ce cadre juridique certes
utile n'est pas suffisant voir qu'il est
dépassé dans s'est établi à proximité
une porosité même pourrait-on dire entre
les pouvoirs publics et l'argent bien
évidemment cette proximité d'autant plus
grande en général et en particulier
c'est à dire je dirais dans le monde et
en france
la frontière entre intérêt général et
intérêt particulier d'autant plus
fragile que l'idéologie libérale voire
ultra libérale que vous défendez prône
la primauté des intérêts privés sur
l'intérêt général de l'économie sur le
politique et que sont imbriqués les
pouvoirs économiques et politiques dans
les classes dirigeantes
ajoutons qu'en france et le débat sur le
cumul des mandats électifs aujourd'hui
ce matin et des mandats dans les
conseils d'administration des grandes
entreprises
hier après midi on était l'illustration
de l'extrême concentration des pouvoirs
tant économiques que politiques dans
notre pays fait partie des champions
ajoutons quelles évolutions récentes
avec la privatisation des grandes
entreprises publiques et des banques
le recours aux partenariats public privé
la délégation croissante de services
publics au privé multiplie les
possibilités des liens étroits entre
pouvoir politique au pluriel et pouvoir
économique au pluriel et les passerelles
entre fonction publique et fonction
économique
ajoutons enfin que cette réalité
d'autant plus affichée depuis l'arrivée
au pouvoir de l'actuel président de la
république que celui ci affiche lui même
sa proximité avec le monde des affaires
il en a fait un symbole en fêtant son
élection au fouquet's avec ses amis de
la finance et sur le yacht de vincent
bolloré
depuis les exemples de proximité se sont
multipliées tant par les nominations de
conseiller du gouvernement à la tête
d'entreprises en voie de privatisation
tant par les rapports étroits de membres
du gouvernement ou de parlementaire avec
le monde des affaires
je n'ai pas l'intention de faire la
chronique des gazettes
par contre ce que tout le monde peut
constater ce sont les nombreuses dérives
sanctionnables ou non au vu de notre
législation actuelle c'est le lot d'une
société hyper médiatisé c'est en quelque
sorte une transparence mais une
transparence extrêmement dangereuse très
dangereuse les dérives de certains
rejaillissent sur tous
elles nourrissent chez nos concitoyens
le rejet des politiques des institutions
et nuit vous nuisent gravement à la
santé de la démocratie
il est navrant de constater qu'au pays
de saint-just de jaurès et de zola 60 à
70 % de nos concitoyens pensent que
leurs élus sont corrompus ou sensibles à
la corruption
on est loin bien loin de la république
irréprochable donc par les paroles
verbales
le candidat nicolas sarkozy à telle
enseigne d'ailleurs qu'à la rentrée de
septembre après un été édifiant sur la
question la prévention des conflits
d'intérêts dans la vie publique est
devenue un sujet d'actualité et qu'une
commission d'experts a été chargé par
décret du 10 septembre 2010 d'y
réfléchir et de faire des propositions
on verra ce que les propositions qui
seront faites par cette commission la
proposition de loi que je défends
aujourd'hui n'est donc pas hors sujet
elle est antérieure à la création de la
commission sur les conflits d'intérêt
même si elle est déposée dans la journée
d'initiative parlementaire aujourd'hui
elle est modeste et s'attache à une
question qui n'est pas forcément
directement liées à
des conflits d'intérêts mais elle traite
de situations bien réels pouvant
concerner non seulement les membres du
gouvernement mais le président de la
république lui-même
je note d'ailleurs que notre rapporteur
signale que cette proposition soulève
des questions cruciales
évidemment pour la repousser ensuite il
avait monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
d'abord tenté de nous y opposer sur la
forme en déposant une motion
d'irrecevabilité
nous savons que la majorité us de
procédure sur la plupart des
propositions de loi de l'opposition pour
éviter les débats de fond
nous en avons des expériences maintenant
nombreuses et répétées au delà de la
forme que nous avons rectifié enr
déposant notre proposition de loi hier
simple en proposition de loi
constitutionnelle notre rapporteur
évoque diverses raisons pour s'y opposer
qui ne me paraissent pas ou peu
convaincante
cette proposition a pour objet d'étendre
au président de la république et aux
membres du gouvernement l'interdiction
de recevoir tout don ou avantage ce
quelque forme que ce soit de personnes
morales et de créer une obligation de
déclaration des dons provenant de
personnes physiques lorsque ces dons
excès d'un montant annuel fixé par la
loi ordinaire vous remarquerez que j'ai
soustrait le montant de la loi
constitutionnelle pour leur envoyer une
loi ordinaire ce qui est juridiquement
normal les dons concernés sont soit
directe soit un direct to do ou
avantages en nature effectué par une
tierce personne dont bénéficie également
les personnes visées par la présente
proposition de loi sont pris en compte
dans le calcul des sommes déclarées
cette nouvelle législation serait
applicable au président de la république
et aux membres du gouvernement
en effet la loi de 1995 exclu
partiellement les bars personne morale
du financement des campagnes électorales
et des partis politiques
mais rien n'est prévu pour précisément
le président de la république et les
membres du gouvernement et les élus une
fois qu'ils sont
telus par ailleurs la loi de 1988 la par
la loi de 1988 la commission de
transparence financière de la vie
politique ctfvp contrôler les
patrimoines des élus en début et fin de
mandat mais ni les revenus ni les
cadeaux et donations qui ne sont pas
patrimoniaux les membres du gouvernement
sont aussi concernés par la loi de 88
rien n'empêche une personne physique ou
une personne morale d'octroyer certain
avantage financier ou en nature de façon
directe ou indirecte aux élus aux
membres du gouvernement ou présidents de
la république monsieur le rapporteur
vous essayez de décrédibiliser notre
proposition en affirmant que notre texte
pourrait priver ministre ou président
des moyens d'exercer leur mandat
je crois monsieur le rapporteur que vous
ne pouvez pas confondre la notion de don
par des personnes morales et celle de
moyens matériels pour l'exercice de
leurs fonctions monsieur le rapporteur
vous nous reprochez de ne pas prévoir de
sanctions afférentes à l'interdiction
des dons que nous préconisons qui
pourrait être limitée même si je renvoie
ceux ci à une loi ordinaire à 4600 euros
comme dans le cadre des campagnes
électorales du financement des partis
politiques
vous auriez pu amendes et en faisant en
proposant des sanctions mais vous êtes
bien discret par contre sur notre
proposition d'améliorer la transparence
en exigeant une déclaration publique de
ces dons chers collègues la transparence
rime avec l'indépendance la sanction
politique et évoque évoque notre
rapporteur c'est à dire le vote comme
seule solution possible en particulier
sur le contre le président de la
république ne pourra intervenir que si
la publicité des liens financiers
existent c'est seulement si les citoyens
sont informés en dehors du jeu
médiatique que leur jugement pourra se
former notre rapporteur considère que
notre proposition aurait pour effet de
réglementer la vie quotidienne de ceux
qui exercent des responsabilités
et et de mettre en quelque sorte leur
vie privée sous les yeux des citoyens
passez moi l'expression mais c'est un
peu fort
nombre de responsables politiques à
commencer par le président de la
république lui-même étalent leur vie
privée ce que nous réprouvons en ce qui
nous concerne
autre chose et la transparence de leur
situation financière
aujourd'hui les médias s'emparent des
dérives inacceptables c'est à la loi
d'organiser la transparence le contrôle
la sanction s'il ya lieu
nul n'est obligé n'est obligé d'être élu
d'être membre d'un gouvernement d'être
président de la république
la contrepartie est d'accepter que sa
situation financière soit public et
d'accepter qu'elle soit irréprochable
mes chers collègues nous défendons
l'honneur des élus qui dans leur grande
majorité n'ont rien à se reprocher et
par là même nous défendons la démocratie
se prononce merci madame la présidente
la parole est à notre collègue patrice
gélard rapporteur de la commission des
lois
je suis en voyage
ce président et ses ministres mes chers
collègues nous sommes donc saisie d'une
proposition de loi pour garantir
l'indépendance du président de la
république et des membres du
gouvernement vis-à-vis du pouvoir
économique
la proposition de loi qui est déposée
par madame la présidente nicole borvo
cohen seat
au nom des membres de son groupe est une
proposition de loi qu'il est loin d'être
inintéressante mais il est vrai que nous
avons déjà eu dans le passé à sa faim
nombre de textes et qui ont régi le
statut du président de la république et
des membres du gouvernement dans les
relations avec les puissances d'argent
ainsi la loi du 11 mars 1988 oblige le
président de la république à faire une
déclaration de patrimoine
ensuite l'évolution du président de ce
patrimoine du président la république
fait l'objet d'un contrôle et on
constate également que nous avons
maintenant une législation intégré dans
le code électoral particulièrement
importante en ce qui concerne d'une part
les élections présidentielles et
notamment les articles l
52 4 52 8 et 52 15 sur l'obligation de
recourir à un mandataire financier sur
la prohibition des dons des personnes
morales et la limitation à 4600 euros la
somme des reversés par une personne
physique et enfin la possibilité de
saisir le parquet en cas d'irrégularité
le ce que nous propose
madame la présidente cohen seat borvo
cohen seat et était à l'origine
irrecevable parce que nous avions une
proposition de loi ordinaire pour
statuer sur le statut du président de la
république nous l'avions souligné c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avions mis
en avant le fait que recourir à une loi
ordinaire
rendez irrecevable une telle loi et
qu'il fallait une réforme
constitutionnelle
cette irrecevabilité tomber comme l'a
dit madame la présidente
pour une raison toute simple c'est que
maintenant nous n'avons plus une loi à
la proposition de loi ordinaire mais une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
cela dit ça me pose un petit problème
une proposition de loi constitutionnelle
de cette nature fera qu elle doit être
approuvée dans les termes identiques par
l'assemblée nationale et par le sénat
transmise au chef de l'état qui sera
libre de recourir ou non au référendum
et un référendum pour un sujet de ce
genre je crains que le référendum
n'entraîne pas l'enthousiasmé des foules
et que nous ayons un nombre considérable
d'abstention aux mamans d'intel d'un tel
vol c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je
regrette
en ce qui me concerne que le neillon pas
adoptée lors de la révision
constitutionnelle récente la nécessité
d'avoir au moins de 50% de votants pour
faire en sorte que le référendum soit
validé je veux faire de cette parenthèse
mais donc la proposition de loi est donc
maintenant recevable mais si elle est
recevable
elle n'est elle pose néanmoins toute une
série de problèmes de problème tout
d'abord c'est une proposition qui est
sans portée juridique pour quelle raison
c'est qu'on prévoyait d'interdiction men
est un texan qui ne constitue ni un
délit ni un crime
par conséquent on pourra faire ce que
l'on veut évidemment ce moralement ce ne
sera pas acceptable
et c'est là où nous retrouvons le
domaine de la vertu en ce qui concerne
les questions posées et non pas que les
problème de droit mais il ne sera pas
pour ce possible de poursuivre les
membres du gouvernement devant la cour
de justice de la république
au cas où il ne respecterait pas les
dispositions prévues par la proposition
de loi quant au président de la
république en dehors du recours à la
haute cour
je ne vois pas prévient qu est ce que
l'on pourrait faire pour poursuivre les
manquements à 7 aux dispositions de
cette proposition de loi
donc à mon avis c'est une proposition de
loi qui n'a pas de portée juridique
puisqu'il n'y a pas de sanctions prévues
à l'égard d'une interdiction
deuxième élément qui me gêne c'est que
le fait que l'on mélange à la fois les
dons et les avantages en est
cela veut dire que si on applique
correctement la proposition de loi qui
nous est aujourd'hui soumise il faudra
que le président de la république des
ménages de l'elysée c'est un avantage en
nature avant donne ses voitures de
fonction c'est un avantage en nature et
il en est de même pour l'ensemble des
ministres
c'est complètement irréaliste à moins à
moins d'imaginer que dorénavant le
président de la république et les
ministres toucheront une liste civile
qui leur permettra de payer comme la
reine d'angleterre
l'intégralité des moyens dont ils ont
besoin cela paraît pas très
deuxième élément toujours dans ce même
domaine on ne peut pas empêcher un chef
de l'état de recevoir des cadeaux des
chefs d'état étrangers lorsqu'il est en
déplacement ou en voyage officiel
c'est impensable ou alors on va créer
des relations diplomatiques à haute
tension dans le cas où nous serions
obligés de refuser à chaque fois les
cadeaux ça ne se fait pas et ensuite
vous avez dit que ça ne touchait pas la
vie privée si en réalité ce que vous
nous proposez ce n'est pas de la preuve
de la transparence c'est du voyeurisme
parce qu'en fin de compte demander est
ce que tous les ministres déclarent tous
les cadeaux qu'ils reçoivent y compris à
l'occasion de leur anniversaire ou à
l'occasion de relations avec leurs amis
ce n'est pas pensable et par conséquent
je ne peux pas accepter ce genre de
choses alors donc il faut arriver à
protéger un peu la vie privée et tous
les dons est temps visés par le texte de
loi à l'exception des donations
familiale et bien on ne voit pas comment
les choses pourraient ce n'est que se
dérouler normalement et puis aussi faut
pas oublier que la proposition de loi
favorise en fait la dissimulation des
dons et des cadeaux on aura tout intérêt
à les cacher parce que les conditions
qui sont prévues de rendre public tout
cadeau fait au président ou à telle ou
telle milice et bien seulement la rend
les choses insupportables
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
décidé dans la commission des lois de ne
pas revoir le texte qui nous est proposé
et d'émettre à l'égard de l'article
unique un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à mme seule ministre à la
marne ex
aussi
voilà monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs vous est saisie
d'une proposition noix du groupe des
sénateurs communistes et apparentés
ayant pour but et je cite de garantir
l'indépendance du président de la
république et les membres du
gouvernement vis-à-vis du pouvoir
économique
elle vise à interdire au président de la
république et aux membres du
gouvernement de recevoir des dons en
espèces ou en nature de la part de
personne morale
et lorsque c'est donc émane d'une
personne physique allait soumettre
chaque année une déclaration publique à
la commission pour la transparence
financière de la vie politique
il y aurait lieu de procéder à cette
déclaration lorsque le montant global de
ces dons ont réalisé par une personne
physique excéderait un montant fixé par
la loi
à l'origine nous étions en présence
d'une proposition de loi ordinaire dans
le sous le contrôle de monsieur le
président de la commission des lois et
de monsieur le doyen gélard le
rapporteur or le contenu des
dispositions relevant clairement d'une
norme supérieure selon les
constitutionnalistes auditionné par le
rapporteur
celui-ci avait proposé à votre
commission des lois qui l'a suivi de
déclarer cette proposition de loi
irrecevable alors cette irrecevabilité
devait être confirmée par le rapporteur
en sciences et le gouvernement vous
aurait demandé de bien vouloir la beauté
cependant devant cette difficulté
juridique les auteurs de la proposition
de transformer celle-ci en une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle qui
insère dans la constitution les mêmes
dispositions que celles qui figuraient
dans la proposition de loi ordinaire
originel compte tenu de ce changement
intervenu hier c'est donc sur le fond
que le gouvernement se placera pour vous
inviter à rejeter cette proposition de
loi
celle ci est celle sur le cumul des
mandats que vous avez envoyé ce matin en
commission doivent être
rapprocher des 4 proposition de loi
présentée par le parti socialiste devant
l'assemblée nationale qui ont été
rejetées par s'ils signent exactement
deux semaines et ce conformément au
souhait du gouvernement
ces quatre propositions de loi était
relative je le rappelle d'une part au
cumul du mandat de parlementaire avec
une fonction exécutive locale d'autre
part à des dispositions portant sur la
réglementation des financements privés
des partis politiques et la prévention
des conflits d'intérêts concernant les
membres du gouvernement les critiques du
gouvernement à l'encontre de ces textes
étaient en substance les suivantes
premièrement il s'agissait de textes
dans la motivation et l évidence
politicienne ce qui la proposait la doc
aucune envie de la pratiquer et
deuxièmement cette motivation avait
conduit à une précipitation dans leur
élaboration et en conséquence à des
défauts que l'on pourrait qualifier
gentiment de technique
le gouvernement avait clairement indiqué
devant l'assemblée nationale par la voix
de votre ancien collègue henri de
raincourt que la défense de la moralité
publique n'était le monopole d'aucun
parti comme aurait pu le laisser
supposer le titre de l'une de ses
propositions de loi vise le site pour
une république décente ferme les
guillemets il avait également mis en
garde les auteurs de ces propositions de
loi contre les risques de démagogie il
avait enfin et le ministre michel
mercier l'a confirmé ce matin devant
vous qu'il n'était pas hostile à ce que
certaines questions évoquées dans ces
différentes propositions de loi soit
l'objet d'un examen moins précipitée et
plus approfondie permettant de parvenir
à des réponses qu'ils soient
effectivement consensuelle ces critiques
le gouvernement peut les reprendre à
l'encontre de la proposition de loi des
sénateurs communistes et apparentés que
nous examinons maintenant l'examen de
cette proposition de loi est l'occasion
pour le gouvernement de rappeler que
notre république s'est doté d'un
ensemble solide de dispositions
juridiques en matière de transparence
financière de la vie politique
vous me permettrez d'ailleurs de faire
observer que les principales lois de ce
dispositif ont été votés alors que
l'actuelle majorité parlementaire était
aux responsabilités ainsi
ainsi ce sont les lois durance mars 1988
sous un gouvernement dirigé par jacques
chirac et du 8 février 95 sous un
gouvernement dirigé par edouard balladur
qui d'une part on réglemente et le
financement des campagnes électorales et
d'autre part organiser le financement
des partis politiques qu'ils soient
privés ou publics
l'ensemble de cette réglementation est
appliquée sous le contrôle de la
commission nationale des comptes de
campagne et des financements publics
acquittent l'ordonance du 8 décembre
2003 prise sous le gouvernement de jean
pierre raffarin a conféré le statut
d'autorité administrative indépendante
mais ce dispositif ne concerne pas
seulement les financements des partis
politiques et des campagnes électorales
il s'intéresse également au patrimoine
des membres du gouvernement et de
nombreux élus ainsi est-il imposées aux
membres du gouvernement de réaliser
notamment une déclaration de leur
patrimoine à la commission pour la
transparence financière de la vie
politique dans les deux mois qui suivent
leur nomination et dans les deux mois de
leur cessation de fonctions à cela
s'ajoute l'obligation de faire état de
toutes les modifications substantielles
de leurs patrimoines intervenus au cours
de leur présence au gouvernement et il
revient à la commission pour la
transparence financière de la vie
politique qui est également considéré
comme une autorité administrative
indépendante d'apprécier le caractère
normal ou non de l'évolution des
patrimoines des uns et les autres lors
cette commission peut d'ailleurs mettre
en demeure les intéressés de donner des
explications quant à certaines
évolutions patrimoniale et si ces
explications lui paraissent
insuffisantes
elle peut saisir le premier ministre et
le parquet s'agissant du financement des
élections présidentielles la loi du 6
décembre 1962 relative à l'élection du
président la république au suffrage
universel reprend les dispositions de
celle du 11 mars 1988 et du fait 8
février 1995 portant sur la transparence
financière de la vie politique que je
viens d'évoquer
enfin en ce qui concerne le
contrôle du patrimoine du président de
la république le système prévu par la
loi du 6 novembre 62 prévoit que les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
doivent remettre au conseil
constitutionnel sous peine de nullité de
leur candidature une déclaration
relative à leur situation patrimoniale
cette déclaration est complété par un
engagement de déposer une nouvelle
déclaration à l'issue du mandat
ces déclarations sont publiés au journal
officiel ainsi tout citoyen peut être
juge de l'évolution du patrimoine du
président de la république pendant la
durée de son mandat
alors mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le gouvernement a beaucoup de
mal à considérer que la réglementation
actuelle relative au financement des
campagnes électorales présidentielles et
au contrôle de l'évolution du patrimoine
du président de la république et des
membres du gouvernement constitue un
ensemble de dispositions anodine et il
le considère avec d'autant plus de
difficultés
s'agissant de la transparence financière
de l'exécutif depuis le début de
l'actuel quinquennat depuis le début de
l'actuel quinquennat
le budget de l'elysée et contrôler
chaque année par la cour des comptes
dont le rapport est rendu public et
contrairement à ce que soutiennent les
rédacteurs de la proposition de loi dans
leur exposé des motifs
on ne peut donc raisonnablement déploré
l'existence d'un vide juridique
concernant le contrôle des relations
entre l'exécutif et le monde économique
et plus généralement l'absence de
dispositif relatif à la transparence
financière de l'exécutif
au contraire nous disposons à cette
matière d'un ensemble solide dont
l'existence pourrait à elle seule
motiver un rouge est au fond de cette
proposition de loi
j'ajouterai si vous le permettez deux
éléments complémentaires à cette raison
de fond qui résulte de la précipitation
dans laquelle elle a été élaborée
premier élément la rédaction du texte
autorise d interprétation extensive qui
conduirait à des interdictions peu
compréhensible le rapport de votre
commission des lois en citer
quelques-uns qu'il s'agisse des moyens
matériels elle voyage et leur l'a
rappelé qu'il s'agisse des moyens
matériels mis à la disposition du
président de la république ou des
membres du
vernement pour assumer leurs fonctions
ou de présents reçus par ceci dans le
cadre de leurs fonctions de
représentation y compris diplomatique
second élément l'application des
dispositions de cette proposition de loi
aurait pour conséquence un contrôle de
la vie quotidienne du chef de l'état et
des membres du gouvernement largement
excessif
je rappellerai enfin que présente la
république et du gouvernement ne sont
pas fermées ne sont pas fermés à toute
prise en considération de la notion de
conflit d'intérêts dans la vie politique
j'en veux pour preuve le décret du 10
septembre 2010 pris à la demande du
président de la république qui a créé
une commission de réflexion sur cette
question s'agissant notamment des
membres du gouvernement
cette commission qui a commencé à
travailler doit remettre son rapport
avant la fin de cette année et au vu de
ces conclusions nous apprécierons s'il
convient de compléter les textes actuels
que j'ai précédemment évoqué donc le
projet de loi organique relatif à
l'élection des députés déjà déposé par
le gouvernement et la proposition de loi
du président de la commission des lois
de l'assemblée nationale relatif à la
simplification du code électoral et à la
transparence financière de la vie
politique pourrait pourrait constituer
des vecteurs législatives susceptibles
d'accueillir d'éventuelles dispositions
portant sur les conflits d'intérêts
entre l'exécutif et le monde économique
voilà pour toutes ces raisons mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs le
gouvernement ait conduit à vous proposer
un rejet de cette proposition de loi
je vous remercie alors dans la suite de
la discussion générale la parole est à
pierre-yves collombat
monsieur le président ce ministre shah
collègues une querelle de famille qui se
transforme en feuilleton où le ministre
de la comptabilité via s'égarer ou le
parquet assume sans complexe son rôle de
bouclier judiciaire du pouvoir un
ex-ministre de la charité prêchant la
fin des conflits d'intérêts à des petits
camarades outragé sur fond de crise qui
s'éternise et de rigueur sélective tel
est le contexte de cette discussion
contexte qui suffit à expliquer la fin
de non recevoir de la majorité
sénatoriale et du gouvernement à la
présente proposition de loi
constitutionnelle
un politicien politiciens et demi
et pourtant ce texte qui concerne
seulement les acteurs les plus
importants de la vie politique s'en
tient à des propositions très modéré on
s'étonnerait n'était le contexte comme
je les dis qu'elle n'aille pas de soi
interdire au président de la république
durant son mandat ainsi qu'aux membres
du gouvernement de recevoir des
avantages en espèces ou en nature de la
part de personnes morales en
l'autorisant de la part de personnes
physiques ce qui prouve préserve la
sociabilité et des liens d'amitié
est ce si scandaleux on pourrait
commencer par là ce à quoi d'ailleurs
nous invite cette proposition de loi
commencer par là avant d'aller plus loin
par exemple en donnant les moyens aux
institutions non c'est déjà la mission
et ce qui a été rappelé d'exercer
correctement ladite mission
il existe un corpus de textes relatifs
aux sujets ainsi qu'une commission pour
la transparence financière de la vie
politique
c'est vrai notre reporter et le ministre
n'a pas manqué de le rappeler mais le
problème c'est que ce corpus est
passablement à trous et que la
commission dont la composition
d'ailleurs et le mode de nomination
pourrait être améliorée ne dispose pas
vraiment des moyens de ses seins le
déplore d'ailleurs régulièrement à
chacun de ses rapports trop d'élus à
contrôler de l'ordre de 3000 des moyens
d'investigation trop limité la
commission n'ayant accès ni au revenu
des intéressés ni à leur dossier fiscal
et ne disposant aucunement du pouvoir de
demander des explications
complémentaires
en tout cas suivi d'effet
obligatoirement en contrôle donc limité
et à la détection des protections in
explique des progressions inexplicable
du patrimoine leurs revenus dépensés ou
évadés se trouve en exclu des
déclarations de patrimoine non publique
et dont l'absence où le caractère
mensonger ne sont pas sanctionnables
à noter la particulière discrétion si
l'on en croit le rapport 2007 de la
commission des dirigeants d'entreprises
publiques puisque donc en 2007
112 nom d'epo été constatée entre gaz de
france et la poste
rien d'étonnant donc que depuis 1983
treize dossiers seulement est connu une
suite judiciaire
aucune d'ailleurs ne visant plus haut
que le niveau du conseiller général
on pourrait aussi s'intéresser au régime
baroque des incompatibilités entre
fonctions gouvernementales mandat
parlementaire et activité
professionnelle
étrangement si on ne peut être sénateur
est professeur de philosophie on peut
être parlementaire et conseiller des
entreprises dans leurs opérations
fiscales de fusions acquisitions ou
vendre des armes et des avions à l'état
rien de plus simple il suffit de ne pas
exercer des fonctions de direction ou d'
influence significative entrant dans le
champ des incompatibilités dans les
filiales de la holding que vous dirigez
laquelle n'entre pas dans le champ des
incompatibilités le byzantinisme
flamboyant des décisions du conseil
constitutionnel qui le confirme
régulièrement mérite chers collègues
toute notre admiration
ce n'est pas un bouclier c'est du
blindage on pourrait aussi étendre les
pouvoirs des commissions dans lequel
parlementaire rendre leur ouverture
possible à la demande de l'opposition
ont levé l'obstacle si commode de
l'ouverture d'une instance judiciaire
le judiciaire jusqu'à plus ample informé
des temps un pouvoir mais une autorité
rien ne l'en pèche par l'absence de
volonté politique
on pourrait aussi s'arrêter sur le
pantouflage multiforme et sur ce que je
qualifierais le pantouflage l'inversé à
savoir la mise en couveuse des futurs
souvent d'ailleurs anciens locaux ou
nationaux et des fonctionnaires à
responsabilités par les grands
délégataire de service public
les grandes entreprises travaillant pour
les collectivités où l'état
ces décideurs parvenus ou revenus aux
affaires pourront en respectant le code
des marchés ce qui nous pose un problème
contractée en toute légalité au nom de
leurs collectivités ou de l'état avec
leur ancien employeur
les marchés publics représentant de
l'ordre de 120 milliards d'euros
par les temps qui courent l'enjeu n'est
pas mince
s'agissant du pantouflage des
fonctionnaires la réglementation
rigoureuse sur le papier ce un cobaye en
fait d'une tolérance molle dans
l'application
quand ce n'est pas d'un encouragement au
nom de la nécessaire perméabilité du
public et du privé au nom de
l'efficacité
quant au pantouflage du personnel
politique il est devenu une pratique
mondialement si courante que sur ce
chapitre
la france est en retard nous manquons en
effet de schröder ou passées au service
de gazprom ou de tony blair pour
conseiller les banquiers mais ce n'est
probablement qu'une question de sport et
nous allons certainement nous moderniser
sur ce chapitre des frontières de plus
en plus diaphane entre haute fonction
publique gouvernement et cabinets
ministériels entourage présidentiel
direction des grands groupes économiques
et financiers publics ou privés organes
de contrôle soit disant indépendants une
classe dirigeante endogamique habitants
les mêmes lotissement parisiens ou
azuréens une oligarchie rompu au jeu des
chaises musicales des renvois
d'ascenseur des participations croisées
quelle place peut-il bien rester à
l'intérêt général
plus fondamentalement cela at-il encore
un sens de demander à l'état moderne
libéral de faire prévaloir de faire
prévaloir l'intérêt général sur les
intérêts particuliers
quand sa fonction est uniquement de
permettre le vivant jeu et le jeu libre
et non faussée des intérêts particuliers
quand l'intérêt collectif est conçu
comme la résultante de ce jeu
concurrentiel manqué au devoir de
probité pour reprendre la formulation du
code pénal at-il encore un sens pour le
serviteur d'un état reformater selon les
principes du management moderne
lequel connaît seulement des coûts et
ignore les valeurs pour qui n'existe
qu'un seul impératif catégorique faire
du profit et s'enrichir le général de
gaulle disait la politique de la france
ne se fait pas à la corbeille
c'était hier aujourd'hui non seulement
la politique se fait à la corbeille et
pour la corbeille
car il faut à tout prix rassure il faut
à tout prix la rassurer puisqu'on s'est
placé entre ses mâchoires
mais il l'était ce pouvoir est installé
au coeur la corbeille est installée au
coeur de l'action publique je voudrais
prendre deux exemples
premier exemple le fonds de réserve des
retraites
il fonctionne ouvertement comme un fonds
spéculatifs ainsi son conseil de
surveillance du 16 juin 2009 après cette
pause avoir constaté les pertes du fonds
suite à la crise
je cite n'entend pas remettre en cause
les bases sur lesquelles il avait fondé
ses choix initiaux à savoir qu'un
investisseur de long terme qui n'a pas
de contraintes de liquidités avant 2020
peut bénéficier dans la durée du
surcroît de performance attendu des
catégories d'actif présentant une
volatilité importante et en particulier
les actions en france et standard ce
jargon signifie que le fonds de réserve
entend bien récupérer par la spéculation
ce qu'ils avaient perdu par la
spéculation
second exemple l' agence des
participations de l'état créé pour je
cite veiller aux intérêts patrimoniaux
de l'état comme si l'état était une
personne privée et pour exercer la
mission de l'état actionnaire dans les
entreprises où celui ci détient des
participations majoritaires ou
minoritaires
problème la mission de l'état
actionnaire et elle de gagner le plus
possible d'argent ou de conduire une
politique industrielle
la réponse ne va pas de soi comme l'a
bien montré la faire eads
je le rappelle 1,2 mo en 2005
eads traverse une crise grave une crise
grave entraînant un plan de suppression
de dix mille emplois et la chute de 35%
en moyenne de son titre seul
l'oligarchie au premier rang desquels
l'ex-coprésident
de eads noël forgeard ancien haut
fonctionnaire et les dirigeants des
groupes lagardère et daimler retirera
ses billes attend en empochant 80
millions de plus values un instant
suspectés de délit d'initié tous les
bénéficiaires seront mis hors de cause
par la neige en novembre 2009 dans la
plus grande discrétion
voilà pour la partie privée s'agissant
de la partie publique qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui on apprendra que fin 2005 le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
de l'époque avait été informé de la
situation par l' agence pour les
participations de l'état
cette agence lui conseillant de se
désengager au plus vite ce thierry
breton n'a pas suivi l'avis de l'agencé
faisant passer la politique aéronautique
de la france avant la protection du
patrimoine de l'état
mais ce dilemme est la preuve que le
conflit d'intérêt est désormais niché au
coeur même de l'état pour en finir avec
les conflits d'intérêts il faudra donc
beaucoup plus que des déclarations
beaucoup plus qu'une réforme des
programmes de l'ena beaucoup plus qu'un
code d'éthique des circulaires ou le
renforcement des pouvoirs des autorités
soit disant indépendante même si comme
je les dis cela ferait pas de mal de
commencer par là on aurait donc plus
aujourd'hui puisque le texte proposé est
inefficace est contestable je reprends
les qualificatifs de notre rapporteur
eh bien on aurait pu le renvoyer en
commission comme on l'a fait ce matin
pour le texte sur le cumul des mandats
pour l'enrichir plutôt que de l'exécuter
je suis cependant d'accord sur un point
avec notre rapporteur
la question posée est d'abord et
essentiellement politique c'est celle
d'une constitution
ça c'est moi qu'il dit qui concentre
l'essentiel du pouvoir politique à
l'elysée sans garantir son indépendance
par rapport au pouvoir économique et
financier c'est celle d'une organisation
politique sans autre contre-pouvoir que
le pouvoir économique et financier mais
en l'espèce peut-on encore parler de
contre pouvoir pourtant pourtant ce
n'est pas pas ce n'est donc pas parce
que cette proposition de loi a des
ambitions
plus modeste que cet immense chantier
qui est devant nous qu'on est fondé à la
rejeter
c'est pour ça que le groupe socialiste
la vôtre à merci si chers collègues de
nous soutenir dans cette action
bravo donc c'est là on s'ennuie jamais
on s'ennuie jamais alors la parole et à
jacques mézard segonzac
pardon
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre que nous retrouvons avec
plaisir en meilleure santé
mes chers collègues ce qui est frappant
c'est qu'il me semble qu'il n'est pas
bon qu'il n'y ait que neuf sénateurs
pour débattre sur la transparence jeu
certes monsieur le président de la
commission des lois la qualité est au
rendez vous mais il y manque quand même
le nombre
notre collègue madame la présidente
borvo cohen seat a eu raison de se
référer à la convention régime qui a
honoré notre nation sous la conduite de
l'incorruptible parfois ça peut être
utile monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
cette proposition de loi nouvellement
constitutionnel nous amène à nous
pencher sur la probité dans la vie
politique
question prégnante dans le débat public
et ce débat dépasse le problème posé par
cette proposition de loi
ils concernent très clairement les
relations du monde politique avec le
monde économique et la justice et il
suffit d'ailleurs de lire cet après-midi
l'article du juge régnard dans le monde
pour s'en convaincre
ce combat est commun à l'ensemble des
responsables politiques de toutes
sensibilité et à juste titre la demande
de transparence de nos concitoyens ne
cesse de croître et dans le même temps
force est de reconnaître que la
confiance qu'ils nous accordent et
fragiliser encore que les élus
municipaux jouissent toujours d'une très
large confiance méritée
mes chers collègues il est impératif de
conforter cette confiance en la chose
publique
certes
certains sondages disent que le chemin
sera long et semé d'embûches avec 60 à
70 % de nos concitoyens qu'ils
considéreraient que leurs élus sont
corrompus ou sensibles à la corruption
mais encore que je me méfie de ce type
de sondage car je ne suis pas du tout
convaincu que cela corresponde à la
réalité et et on le voit bien
lorsque l'on voit la confiance qui est
accordée par nos concitoyens je les dis
à leurs élus de terrain cet état de fait
a été en grande partie causée par les
trop nombreuses affaires qui ont émaillé
la vie politique
au cours de chaque république de chaque
régime les je tiens à écarter
immédiatement toute polémique partisane
aucun bord politique ne peut se
prévaloir d'être ou d'avoir été exempt
de comportement contestable
aucun camp n'a le monopole de l'éthique
et de l'honnêteté
mais ce n'est pas là l'unique raison le
manque de transparence la légèreté du
cadre juridique qui entoure nos statuts
ont été le terreau de cette véritable
défiance accéléré il faut le dire par
les crises financières ce fut le cas en
ce fut le cas en 2008 mais de grâce ne
tombons pas dans un antiparlementarisme
inacceptable utilisée par les véritables
ennemis de la démocratie
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche en
s'intéressant à la question de
l'indépendance des membres du
gouvernement et du chef de l'état nous
ne pouvons faire l'économie de l'étude
de la question du conflit d'intérêts
notion large protéiforme ne faisant
l'objet d'aucune définition légale ou
jurisprudentielle le conflit d'intérêt
est pourtant au coeur de l'actualité
politique de ces derniers mois l'un des
premiers à s'y être intéressé est sans
conteste le duc de la rochefoucauld qui
dans une phrase célèbre nous rappeler
que les vertus se perdent dans l'intérêt
comme les fleuves dans la mer plus
récemment on peut se référer aux travaux
de l' ocde et aux recommandations du
conseil de son conseil en date du 28 mai
3 et à la lecture de la définition ocde
on constate aisément que les situations
de conflit d'intérêts ne concerne pas
uniquement les membres du gouvernement
mais l'ensemble des décideurs publics
c'est en ce sens qu avec plusieurs de
nos collègues sous la conduite de michel
charasse à l'époque le groupe rdse avait
déposé l'année dernière une proposition
de loi tendant à interdire à réglementer
le cumul des fonctions et des
rémunérations de dirigeants d'une
entreprise du secteur public et d'une
entreprise du secteur privé
l'existence d'intérêts publics et privés
divergent voire opposées ne peuvent
aller qu'à l'encontre de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'état
je fais remarquer que notre proposition
de loi adoptée ici même il ya près d'un
an n'a toujours pas fait l'objet d'un
examen à l'assemblée nationale la
présente proposition de loi je crois
partage cet objectif global et même si
elle se consacre uniquement à la
manifestation la plus voyante du conflit
d'intérêts que constitue
l'enrichissement personnel rappelle que
l' ocde a dégagé cette situation créant
les conditions de potentiels conflits
d'intérêt aujourd'hui dans notre
législation des failles demeure très
clairement il est important de ne pas
non plus je les dis noircir le tableau
et de rappeler qu'un contrôle du
patrimoine des membres du gouvernement
et du président de la république
existent déjà dont la double déclaration
de patrimoine
toutefois les modalités du contrôle
divergent pour les membres du
gouvernement il est effectué par la
commission pour la transparence de la
vie politique sans sanction directe pour
le président le système retenu est celui
du contrôle du peuple lequel est censé
ne pas redonner sa confiance en cas de
pratiques douteuses
c'est un autre débat durant les
campagnes présidentielles le contrôle et
accru les dons provenant personnes
morales sont interdits quand ceux
émanant des personnes physiques sont
limités à 4600 euros
pourtant il est dommageable que de
telles limitations n'ai pas cours durant
l'exercice des fonctions ministérielles
nous avons proposé des pistes ambitieuse
pour renforcer le contrôle des membres
du gouvernement et du président de la
république tout en sachant que de
nombreux obstacles devront être
franchies pour parvenir à davantage de
moralisation et de limpidité de la vie
politique
nous considérons comme impératif que les
auteurs d'infractions liées à l'exercice
d'un mandat politique fasse
systématiquement l'objet de poursuites
pénales
l'image de l'état en général et des
politiques et magistrats en particulier
et meurtri par les affaires que nous
connaissons je crois que la chancellerie
doit avoir le courage de prendre une
directive générale de politique pénale
sur le trafic d'influencé la prise
illégale d'intérêt en donnant mandat au
parquetier de poursuivre les auteurs de
ce type d'infraction dont on se rendra
compte d'ailleurs qui sont pas très
nombreux et les exemples sont parfois et
même souvent utile dans la république
mes chers collègues afin de ne pas
revivre le fiasco estival
il est essentiel d'étendre les
incompatibilités ministériel et
d'interdire qu'un ministre directement
ou indirectement et des intérêts dans
des entreprises publiques ou privées
associations ou organismes soumis au
contrôle de son administration et il
faudra bien régler la question du cumul
des mandats électifs avec des mandats
d'administrateurs de grandes sociétés ou
celle de l'inflation des avocats
d'affaires parlementaire ce n'est pas à
main ce dossier mais c'est une réalité à
laquelle il faudra bien s'attaquer
loin de moi l'idée de jeter l'opprobre
sur la classe politique à laquelle je
suis fier d'appartenir
je crois qu en affranchissant en
l'affranchissant des intérêts privés
nous redonnerons leur liberté d'élus et
de citoyens et c'est tout à fait
indispensable alors nous considérons que
le texte qui nous est présentée
mériterait d'être complétée d'abord
parce qu aucune sanction n'est prévue
que le contrôle de la véracité de la
déclaration de son absence pure et
simple de moeurs je crois que il aurait
peut-être aussi été utile d'attendre les
conclusions de la commission de
réflexion pour la prévention des
conflits d'intérêts dans la vie publique
présidée par monsieur sauver
ceci étant
malgré quelques réticences technique
nous considérons que poser ce problème
comme le fait cette proposition de loi
est utile et en conséquence la majorité
des membres de mon groupe apportera son
soutien à cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle car elle lutte où elle
entend lutter contre le mélange des gens
ce qui est tout à fait malheureux pour
l'image aujourd'hui de notre vie
publique
merci jacques mézard la parole est à
eliane assassi
allez
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers neuf collègues le
pouvoir et l'argent ne font pas bon
ménage
mais les conflits d'intérêts semble
avoir de beaux jours devant eux si nous
ne nous décidons pas à endiguer ces abus
la démocratie est en grand danger
lorsque des proximités se développe
entre les pouvoirs publics et l'argent
en témoignent les nombreuses dérives
auxquelles nous avons récemment assisté
les frontières entre ces deux sphères
sont terriblement poreuse à tel point
qu'on en vient à décorer les heureux
contributeurs de la campagne
présidentielle de 2007 de la légion
d'honneur transformant ainsi la médaille
napoléonienne embauché pour riches
je ne vais pas toutes les citer ici met
trop d'affaires font prendre aujourd'hui
à la france des allures de république
bananière alors il me semble qu'elles
sont ces affaires sont très éloignées de
l'exigence démocratique de transparence
que beaucoup semblent appeler de leurs
voeux au moins par le verbe
ce qui semble visiblement difficile
lorsqu'il faudrait passer aux actes
de même que la privatisation des moyens
de renseignements les généreux cadeaux
fiscaux le cumul des fonctions et les
logging installé au coeur du pouvoir
témoigne d'une mise sous tutelle
inacceptable de l'état par des personnes
morales nous avons donc modifié la
rédaction de notre proposition de loi
puisqu'il nous était argué qu'elle était
inconstitutionnelle et qu'elle devait
relever du domaine d'intervention de la
loi organique
mais on regarde tous ces scandales
politico-financiers on pourrait
considérer que l'ensemble de la
politique de monsieur sarkozy est dans
son ensemble inconstitutionnelle dès
lors que l'article cadre d'autres lois
fondamentales dispose que je cite les
partis et groupements politiques
concourent à l'expression du suffrage
universel
ils se forment et exercent leur activité
librement
ils doivent respecter les principes
de la souveraineté nationale et de la
démocratie fin de citation nous sommes
donc aujourd'hui très loin du compte
nos concitoyens nous ont mandatés pour
les représenter les écouter les relayer
nos mandats politiques ne doivent pas en
théorie permettre à quiconque d'agir
avec cupidité car un état et
démocratique dans le sens où chacun
concède son pouvoir décisionnel non à un
autre individu ou un groupe déterminé
mais à la société dont il constitue une
composante il n'en demeure pas moins
qu'aujourd'hui le pouvoir est
invariablement détenus et transmis au
sein d'un groupe particulier la grande
majorité de la population se trouve
exclu de l'élaboration de nos politiques
publiques ce qui est vous en conviendrez
fortement dommageable pour ce qui reste
de notre état de droit et de notre
république
nous regrettons d'ailleurs que notre
pays ne se soit pas acheminée vers
l'établissement d'une véritable
démocratie participative
le 12 juillet dernier à l'occasion de
son intervention sur france 2 qui visait
à désamorcer la bombe burt's bées donc
bidon bettencourt le président de la
république déclarait je le cite qu'il
donc lui demanderai à une commission
représentant toutes les familles
politiques de réfléchir à la façon dont
on doit ou non compléter ou modifier la
loi pour éviter dans l'avenir toute
forme qui pourrait intervenir de conflit
d'intérêts fin de citation
admettons donc admettant donc de fait
qu'il y avait un problème
suite à la publication du livre de
monsieur hirsch faisant état de
situation quelque peu gênante trois
personnalités un magistrat un conseiller
taille un président de la cour des
comptes ont été donc récemment chargé
par le président de la république de
réfléchir aux situations de conflit
d'intérêts dans lesquelles peuvent se
trouver les membres du gouvernement les
responsables des établissements publics
et entreprises publiques ainsi que le
cas échéant les autres agents publics
dont la nature particulière des missions
le justifierait
en tant que parlementaire et au titre du
mandat qui nous a été confié nous
vion pour notre part prendre la
responsabilité d'agir face à la
multiplication des dérives confortée par
une législation lacunaires en la matière
nous avons donc été incités à développer
notre réflexion sur l'indépendance du
pouvoir exécutif et à vouloir aller plus
loin dans notre détermination à
combattre ces abus la législation
actuelle
beaucoup s'accordent pour le reconnaître
présente des insuffisances temps dans
son champ d'application qui est
aujourd'hui limité aux seuls partis et
candidats que dans l'effectivité son
application l'interdiction faite aux
personnes morales de participer à la vie
politique du pays ne concerne que les
périodes de campagne électorale et le
financement des partis politiques
alors qu'elle devrait concerner
l'ensemble de la vie politique
afin de remédier à cette contradiction
nos propositions donc ont pour objet
d'étendre l'interdiction de recevoir
tout don ou avantages sous quelque forme
que ce soit de personnes morales et de
créer une obligation de déclaration des
dons provenant de personnes physiques
lorsque c'est donc excède un montant
annuel fixé par la loi ordinaire
alors nous nous disons qu'il pourrait
être de 4600 euros à l'instar de la
législation actuelle en matière de
financement de la campagne des candidats
à une élection comme l'a rappelé nicole
borvo les dons concernés sont soit
directe ou indirecte ou dont en avant ou
avantages en nature effectué par une
tierce personne dont bénéficie également
les personnes visées par notre texte
sont pris en compte dans le calcul des
sommes déclarées
cette nouvelle législation serait non
seulement applicable au président de la
république mais aussi aux membres du
gouvernement ceux là étaient les
sanctions envisagées sont celles prévues
par la constitution pour le président de
la république et par la loi du 11 mars
1988 relative à la transparence
financière de la vie politique pour les
membres du gouvernement cette
proposition de loi n'a nulle autre objet
que de renforcer la transparence de la
vie politique je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure qui semble être appelé par
beaucoup en accord avec la loi suprême
de notre république à savoir le respect
et de la souveraineté nationale il nous
sommes que la démocratie ne peut trouver
son accomplissement que dans une société
où les hommes librement associés exerce
activement leur souveraineté sans s'en
faire dépouiller par d'insidieux
dispositifs politiques ou autres
copinage de circonstance pour réaliser
la démocratie il ne faut pas seulement
que les décisions soient prises en
accord avec la majorité mais qu'elles
soient prises pour la majorité
et c'est tout le sens de nos
propositions s'il y en a ça si et le
dernier orateur inscrit robert lofo à
hulu vous avez la parole
monde
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
préoccupation constante et responsables
politiques
la volonté d'écarter tout soupçon
d'enrichissement par une suggestion à la
sphère économique a fait l'objet de
plusieurs évolutions législatives la loi
du 11 mars 1988 relative à la
transparence financière est une
concrétisation de cette volonté
un candidat à une élection où un parti
politique ne peuvent plus recevoir des
dons de la part d'une personne morale
de plus afin de démontrer que leur
fonction n'a pas été source
d'enrichissement personnel
les élus sont soumis à une obligation de
déclaration de leur patrimoine au début
et à la fin de leur mandat
ce mécanisme de contrôle et même
renforcé à l'égard des candidats à la
présidence de la république
en effet à peine de nullité de leur
candidature les candidats sont tenus de
remettre au conseil constitutionnel une
déclaration de leur situation
patrimoniale la suite
par la suite la loi du 8 février 1995 a
étendu cette obligation de déclaration
aux membres du gouvernement et aux
titulaires de certaines fonctions comme
l'affirmé récemment le président de la
république et je le cite
il ne suffit pas que la république soit
irréprochable
il faut encore que l'on puisse même être
soupçonné de ne pas l'être
à cet égard le texte présenté par madame
borvo cohen seat
plusieurs membres du groupe crc spg vise
à renforcer la transparence entre le
monde politique et le monde des affaires
on regarde la rectification des auteurs
de la proposition de loi pour pour la
modifier en proposition de loi
constitutionnelle de dispositions sont
ainsi proposés en un article unique
la première vise à interdire au
président de la république
aux membres du gouvernement pendant
toute la durée de leur mandat de
recevoir des dons des personnes morales
la seconde a pour objet de soumettre les
dons des personnes physiques au régime
de déclaration obligatoire comme l'a
souligné notre rapporteur patrice gélard
si cette proposition de loi poursuit
l'objectif légitime d'encadrer des
cadeaux et avantages en nature qui
pourraient être effectués au profit du
président de la république et des
membres du gouvernement
son dispositif comporte d'importantes
lacunes
en effet le texte qui est soumis à notre
examen aujourd'hui présente de limite
majeure
quant à son opportunité d'une part et
quand dans l'efficacité de son
dispositif d'autre part
tout d'abord ce texte semble prématuré à
l'initiative du président de la
république il commission de réflexion
pour la prévention des conflits
d'intérêts dans la vie publique a été
mise en place en vue de traiter la
question de la régularité de la
régulation des relations entre les
responsables politiques et le milieu des
affaires
présidée par monsieur sauver la
commission doit rendre ses conclusions
avant le 31 décembre 2010 il serait donc
opportun de légiférer sur cette question
inès avant même que la commission est
achevé ses travaux
par ailleurs ce texte instaure un
mécanisme inopérant en effet il présente
une profonde la cuite et en proposant de
soumettre les membres de l'exécutif à
l'interdiction de percevoir des dons
sans qu'il n'était prévu de sanction si
ce dispositif n'est pas respectée de
plus la notion d' avantages en nature ne
saurait fonder juridiquement une telle
interdiction dans ses acceptions son
flow et pourrait faire l'objet d'une
interprétation extensive comme l'a
présenté notre rapporteur à titre
d'exemple et je le cite
avec un tel mécanisme serait désormais
interdit aux membres de l'exécutif de se
rendre en vacances chez des amis
si ceux ci ont acheté
leur maison sous la forme d'une société
civile immobilière laisser y étant les
personnes morales le fait de jouir d'une
habitation ainsi constitué tomberait en
effet sous le coup de l'interdiction de
recevoir des avantages en nature
procurés par les personnes morales nous
voyons bien ici que les faiblesses de
cette proposition de loi pourrait
conduire à des situations absurdes et
induire les sanction totalement
disproportionnée d'autant plus qu'elle
soeur à la nécessaire protection de la
vie privée des membres de l'exécutif
pour ces raisons le groupe ump votera
contre cette proposition vient alors la
discussion générale est close
la commission n'ayant pas élaboré de
texte ou passons à la discussion de
l'article unique de la proposition de
loi initiale
y at il une deux alors qui arrive que
l'on bat sur l'arctique ludique
ne soyons pas nombreux je veux qu'il me
doit partir comme ça je voudrais
répondre répondre aux objections plus
précise que notre rapporteur a fait est
que le ministre a repris et puis notre
notre collègue aussi donc premier
première volée d'arguments ce texte est
inefficace parce que il ne comporte pas
il a c'est une obligation sans sanction
bon chacun chers collègues c'est quand
même pas une particularité de ce texte
dire le nombre de textes que nous votons
où il ya des déclarations et sans
sanction de dire qu'il y en a il y
aurait quand même un beau paquet et
notamment à qui sont présentés par la
majorité la majorité sénatoriale bon
très bien et une remarque c'est
exactement le cas de ce qui se passe
pour les comptes de campagne du
président de la république
vous imaginez le conseil constitutionnel
c'est possible oh la la non mais vous
vous imaginez le cross et crostis yann l
non monsieur sarkozy ne pourra élu parce
que vous savez là on n'est pas trop sur
ça n'a rigoureusement aucun sens la lan
dont que séparent les deux
particularités de ce 2 de ce texte la
notion nous dit-on serait trop large et
on est revenu plusieurs fois là dessus
on ne pourrait le nom du gouvernement
présent de république ne pourrait plus
avoir de logement de fonction ou de
voitures enfin c'est pas des avantages
en nature ou c'est ce sont les voitures
de fonction et les logements c'est par
obligation de service que ça fait partie
du service
non mais ça fait partie du service bon
donc c'est un argument qui ne tient
absolument pas le problème des cadeaux
des étangs des chefs d'état étrangers
dans des deux choses l'une où c'est le
cadeau un chef d'état étranger un chef
d'état français
auquel cas c'est une affaire d'état et
le cadeau en question où va rejoindre le
musée comme ça se fait parfois du
président de la république en question
il ya des touristes qui vont le voir de
temps en temps ou sait où c'est une
relation personnelle entre les gens et
se sait parfaitement parfaitement toléré
parfaitement admissible dans le cadre de
cette tendance dans le cadre de ce texte
le problème dsi vous avez failli me
faire pleurer je veux dire on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas avoir le beurre
l'argent du beurre etc
on sait à quoi sert les ailes si elles
ont leur intérêt bon ce sont
effectivement des personnes morales ma
foi si vous voulez aller habiter chez
votre votre ami président des états unis
va vous allez dans sa maison qui n'est
pas une et qui n'est pas propriété d'une
essais il n'y a pas de problème
particulier
vous nous dites aussi il ya de larges
possibilités de contournement
là encore une fois on passe son temps à
faire des lois qui prouve bien que celle
qui avait également été contournée bon
donc essayer encore une fois ce n'est
pas un argument qui est quand même qui
est quand même de grands de poids est
alors le meilleur c'est quand même le
problème de la protection de la vie
privée
bon d'abord une personne publique d'un
pas exactement aux normes la même ville
même vie privée qu'une qu'une personne
qui ne l'est pas et puis d'autre part
vous savez comme moi que la mise en
scène de la vie privée est maintenant
devenu une arme de gouvernement une
moyens de gouverner enfin je veux pas
vous faire de dessin vous le savez vous
le savez comme moi le fils la femme le
et cetera le président qui faisait son
jogging sur son vélo qui va manger de la
pizza au cap
enfin je vais pas vous raconter nice
matin bon dire c'est véritablement oui
je vous rapporte à monsieur le président
c'est extrêmement intéressant
dire que cette mise en scène de la vie
privée c'est quand même une outils de
gouvernement aujourd'hui
s'agissant maintenant notre doyenne ou
10 est contestable
le manquement à la probité personnelle à
manquement à la probité personnelle
sanctions politiques
moi je suis d'accord avec ça sauf que
actuellement les élus autres que ceux
qui sont visés par le texte de loi et
qui manqueraient à la probité sont
soumis au code pénal
eux ils le sont soumis il ya toute une
liste vous savez mieux que moi et que
sauf que le système le système français
actuel à la fois constitution est encore
plus pratique
en fait que c'est un régime que j'aime à
appeler consulaires c'est à dire où il
n'y a pas ou il n'y a pas de
contre-pouvoirs où le pouvoir fait
exactement ce qu'il veut où il n'ya pas
de contrôle alors si seule la sanction
électorale est recevable ce moment là
quid des membres du gouvernement qui
sont pas des élus même
constitutionnellement ils peuvent pas
l'être
quid des dispositions et des organismes
comme le conseil constitutionnel qui qui
existe mais que les électeurs ne peuvent
pas mettre mettre en cause ensuite on
dit que c'est prématuré bon puisqu'il ya
une commission qui a été mis en place ce
qui prouverait quand même que si une
commission qui est mise en place c'est
qu'il y avait un petit problème
alors pour conclure je dirais que ce
ce dispositif qui est proposé n'est pas
plus n'est pas plus inefficace que
l'absence de dispositif actuel il n'a
d'inutiles il n'a rien d'inutile et son
exigence n'est pas n'est pas contestable
comme le montre bien ce que je viens de
dire la nomination de cette fameuse
commission pour la prévention des
conflits d'intérêts de la vie publique
si à mon avis ne réglera pas parce que
le problème c'est pas là c'est pas des
problèmes de conflits d'intérêts
j'essaie des problèmes de moralité
publique si pierre yves collombat madame
la présidente nicole borvo cohen seat
vous avez la parole merci monsieur veut
pas inutilement rallonger le débat vous
en doutez et bon yves collombat vient de
reprendre
c'est vraiment de réponse aux arguments
que j'avais moi même et où il ya ne sait
si développer dans nos interventions
mais je vais quand même vous dire
quelque chose parce que je suis
franchement très surprise qu'il me soit
en outre en plus du rapport et mais
c'était un rapport d'ailleurs opposé que
cette loi susciterait des contournements
à voyez ça c'est vraiment une conception
de la transparence et de des obligations
faites à des élus de la république et de
personnes dotées les plus hautes
responsabilités qui franchement que je
trouve inacceptables parce que de deux
choses l'une où la transparence la
probité le respect de la morale publique
fait partie de notre consensus
républicain et de ce que nous pouvons
avoir en commun et auquel cas le fait
d'imposer des principes et de faire en
sorte que les personnes publiques doté
de ses responsabilités s'y conforment
avec évidemment des garde-fous qui
appartiennent qui permettent à toutes
les personnes faiblesses humaines de
faillir en quelque sort sera fait aux
hommes de faillir pardon mais dire que
l'on va susciter le contournement c'est
à dire que justement c'est à dire que l
inverse les hommes publics et femmes
dotées de d'éminentes responsabilités
n'auront qu'une idée c'est de contourner
ces règles ça me paraît quand même
triste et de peu de faim si vous voulez
ne devrait pas avoir sa place dans
l'hémicycle voilà donc vous refusez
conte de cette proposition de loi
vous savez comme je lé noté d'autres
l'ont fait aussi aujourd'hui les
conflits d'intérêts devienne un objet
d'actualité c'est sans doute vous y être
pour quelque chose mais en tout cas dans
tous les sens du terme
en tout cas nous serons là pour dire ce
que nous avons à dire deux camps les
choses la paix la commission fera ses
conclusions et sans doute pour
solliciter qu'elle se traduise si elles
sont pertinentes
en gros un texte cette voie là merci
madame la présidente
il ya plus de demandes de parole donc je
vais mettre aux voix l'article unique
constituant l'ensemble de la proposition
de loi constitutionnelle
je rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 59 du règlement le scrutin
public et de droit
il va être procédé dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement
pour un bulletin blanc contre un
bulletin bleu l'abstention un bulletin
rouge de scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques instants
alors je rappelle que le gouvernement et
la commission sont défavorables
le scrutin est ouvert
bien le scrutin est clos et j'invite
mesdames et messieurs les secrétaires a
procédé au dépouillement du scrutin